so as we continue our I guess our
discussion on DC rebirth we pick up now
with Action Comics rebirth and the story
Superman meets Clark Kent now before we
get into this again something I want to
do is draw your eyes to the description
where you'll find my updated schedule on
video releases but with actually comics
rebirth this is one of the best runs in
its entirety of of DC we breath now I am
actually going to skip over the Superman
versus doomsday conflict for a second
and the reason why is because I want to
come back to that but I want to focus on
this character of Clark Kent I want to
talk about this because this is
something I've been wanting to discuss
for quite some time because of such a
huge twist we've never really seen
anything like this that's last any
measure of time and this is one of the
reasons why I like DC rebirth so much
the entire concept of Action Comics
rebirth really has its roots in in the
new 52 Darkseid war and Superman truth
and what I mean here is during the
events of Superman truth the new 52
Superman's identity as Clark Kent was
dispersed throughout the world everybody
came to to know who he was and so that's
one of the reasons why when the pre new
52 Superman showed up a lot of people
said you know that's not Superman so on
and so forth but this also ties directly
into the question of who Clark Kent is
and what I mean is during Action Comics
rebirth yes the fight dealt with
Superman vs doomsday but it was it
wasn't the most extreme thing it wasn't
the most insane thing ever it was a
really cool conflict and it was really
just an example of how doomsday always
learns from what defeats him and it was
just kind of like cementing the pre new
52 Superman and his place in the new 52
universe as the new Superman but the
factory-made here that the undercurrent
under all this was Clark Kent and the
reason why I say that is an Action
Comics rebirth Clark Kent had just shown
up as a guy and it was funny because
Jimmy Olsen had asked the question will
your Superman like I know you're
Superman the world knows you're Superman
go fight doomsday and Clark Kent kept
saying no I'm not Superman and that's
the one thing he kept saying all
throughout the action comic story every
time people saw him they said why are
you letting that Superman fight doomsday
you should go fight him and Clark Kent
kept saying no I'm not Superman I am
just Clark Kent I'm just a guy now we
didn't really get an answer to the
question and in fact DC was holding that
to this story art we didn't know who
this Clark kid was we
didn't know where he came from we didn't
know what his whole story was and our
mine he was kind of left to our own
devices and it was interesting reading
all these different theories online
because people were saying well maybe
the Superman Clark Kent persona split
and they were one individual but now
they're two separate individuals when
the new 52 Superman died the Clark Kent
persona took on a mind of its own so to
speak you know there were all these
different theories that were floating
around we were just kind of having to
wait into the story was release but what
this does is this picks up with Clark
Kent as the reporter giving the people
trying to kill him now this is kind of
cool here because this is basically damn
Jergens focusing on what Clark Kent's
capable of as just a regular guy and
this is something that we never saw
because again in previous stories since
the beginning of the Superman mythos in
1938 Clark Kent would always just race
off become Superman
come back fight bad guys and then become
Clark Kent again that was just as that
was his thing that's just how he
functioned but in the story you know
Clark Kent's holding his own against
various forces and talking about how the
life of a reporter puts him in jeopardy
all the time and this is interesting
because this is kind of like something
we would expect from from Lois Lane Lois
Lane would be the one to say well being
a reporter constantly puts you in danger
being a reporter constantly puts you in
a situation where your life's and life's
in danger and so we might try to kill
you so to see Clark Kent make this case
is a little interesting to me but the
fact remains here that once he gets past
you know all these things we realize
that he's actually been brought onto a
stage at the request of Lex Luthor now
this is where I want to get into a
little explanation of where we stand
with a Superman mythology at the moment
the following the events of the death of
the new 52 Superman because he was gone
and because the three new 52 Superman
hadn't quite become the world's
superhero that is to say he hadn't quite
stepped into the role of being part of
the Justice League and things like that
Lex Luthor took it upon himself to use
the remnants of Darkseid forces to
basically use a mother box to power a
new form of lex luthor armor that had
the superman sigil and the goal was for
lex luthor to basically step into the
role of being superman now this was a
long time coming it had really been this
way since forever evil it had really
been this way since lex luthor led
villains against the forces of the
crimes from the kid and save the world
and so this reformation of luthor
becoming a good guy has just it was
always sort of leading to this point we
didn't know it was
lead him taking of the mantle of
Superman but it always sort of made
sense to be honest so because Lex Luthor
was such a formidable foe of Superman
and had been for so long it's like the
Batman Joker dichotomy you know if if
Batman is dead will the Joker's purpose
ceases to be if Superman's dead then Lex
Luthor's purpose ceases to be and so
we'd have to find some way to make up
for that but because he was on the road
to you know to becoming a good guy it
made sense that he would take on the
mantle of becoming Superman but the fact
remains here that because of the fact
that everybody had witnessed the pre-new
30 to fight doomsday and because it had
given rise to the question of what's
going on with this Clark Kent character
the entire basis behind this predicate a
press conference is to answer that
question for Clark Kent to get up on
stage and to tell the world his story to
answer the questions of why it is that
Clark Kent and Superman were both seen
in the same place at the same time now
one of the other cool things here is
that this entire press conference is
being watched by the pre new 52 Superman
new is being watched by him and his
family the issue here is that once they
start to get into the discussion once
they start to have this debate one guy
freaks out and immediately starts
shooting at Clark now it's not in an
effort to actually kill him instead this
guy genuinely believes that Clark Kent
and Superman and his lying and so what
he wants to do is shoot Clark Kent to
prove that he's Superman by virtue of
the fact that the bullets would just
bounce off of him of course he is
subdued he's not successful in shooting
Clark Kent but the fact is that all
these people that he's been running into
seem to have been doing this to there at
the very least that seems to be the
indication but once his press conference
ends of course he's back at the Daily
Planet talking to Perry White and so on
and so forth and he succumbs to a
holograph test now the polygraph test is
designed to of course determine whether
or not Clark in telling the truth and a
series of baseline questions or answer
for those of you guys who don't know
of course polygraph tests are basically
not admissible when it comes to the
judicial system simply because they
could be faked
you know there's a lot of different
reasons why you can't use them but you
know there are less savory organizations
out there that will use a polygraph test
and whatever polygraph test is
administered a series of baseline
questions are asked in order to
determine heart rate whenever an honest
answer is given so that's why they'll
ask things like you know is your name
such-and-such you know or they'll ask is
your skin white or are you wearing a red
right now they'll ask a series of
general questions that you obviously
cannot lie about and so that way they'll
be able to determine a baseline to
determine whether you are actually lying
now of course Clark Kent passes the test
he says that he is Clark Kent he is not
Superman
Perry White seems to be satisfied but
again we as the reader just kind of left
where we're kind of asking the question
is this really true is this really
what's going on by now and so what
happens is as as Clark Kent makes his
way out onto the street as you know
talking to various individuals so on and
so forth doing his job as a reporter and
inciting the wrath of these people who
are trying to kill him he's actually
rescued by Superman
now something I also want you to take
note of here is that there's a guy with
a beard who is watching all these events
unfold now who this man is we don't know
yet we don't really know who he is or
what he's about or where he's from
there's some speculation but again this
is just an example Ward is kind of left
to our own devices here now Dan Jergens
will undoubtedly reveal this at a future
point in time but for right now you know
the entirety of the story shifts its
focus to Clark Kent and Superman it
shifts the focus to giving us the
answers that we that we have on the
question of who is Clark Kent the
question of where did he come from
you know what's his whole backstory and
so what we do here is we jump to the
fortress of solitude now again if those
of you guys who have been reading
Superman since the beginning of the new
you'll recognize aspects of this of
course when the pre new 52 Superman
showed up to take the place of the new
52 Superman when he died he basically
just adopted the new 52 Superman's
fortress of solitude now he made a
couple changes but for the most part he
didn't change much and the reason why is
because in the mind of Superman he
wanted to pay homage to his predecessor
he wanted to pay homage to the new 52
version of Superman who had fought and
saved the world so many times and so it
would seem disrespectful to go through
and just change everything around it
and have everything be adjusted and so
even if it's really just you know a
testament to the new 52 Superman's
version of Krypton and his legacy and so
on and so forth for the pre new 52
Superman it's a tribute to the new 52
Superman so on and so forth but the fact
remains here that Superman brought Clark
in here for the purpose of finding
answers for the purpose of figuring out
what exactly it is that he knows who he
is and where he comes from and so what
happens is the pre new 52 Superman grabs
a
device that's able to more or less tell
the life of a person to see their past
to see who they are where they came from
and so he has Clark Kent expose himself
to this he has Clark Kent
basically immerse himself in this device
so that we as the reader will learn who
he is and what we find out is that this
Clark Kent is not Superman and he never
was he had his own life he was raised by
his own family he was you know he dated
and so on and so forth he had his own
history his own legacy the issue here is
that when the new 52 Superman first
popped up because of the fact that this
Clark Kent existed because they looked
so similar to one another the issue was
people will undoubtedly come after this
Clark Kent come after the real Clark
Kent and so what Superman did what the
new 52 Superman did is he sent Clark
Kent into hiding
he basically set him away from the eyes
of the world to ensure that no one would
ever come after him the issue was that
one side the new 52 Superman powers
began to dissipate this plan seemed to
go up in smoke in its entirety and so
Clark Kent was effectively pulled out he
would he he really didn't have anywhere
to go when the new 52 Superman died the
entire purpose of the plan was no longer
you know an issue anymore now it's
something to point out here is that the
re-emergence of Clark Kent did not
account for the return of the pre new 52
Superman because remember when the pre
new 52 Superman first showed up in DC
Comics you know it's part of the new 52
no one knew he was there you know he'd
know knew that he was around the Justice
League didn't know you know Batman
didn't know no one knew that he was
there now this is really just a
testament to the experience of the pre
knew that he teased Superman the fact
that he knows how to work around the
intelligence of Bruce Wayne he knows how
to avoid detection you know by the
Justice League Watchtower assuming that
it had any real similarity to the one
that he was familiar with in the pre new
52 universe but he knew how to stay
hidden and so because of the fact that
no one knew about the pre new 52
Superman Clark Kent said well if the new
52 Superman is dead there's probably not
going to be any concern for me so I can
just you know come out of hiding again
and so this is basically just DC telling
us here's what's going on with this this
version of Clark Kent now there will be
more that goes on here there will be
more that happens here but what Dan
Jergens also does is he gives us a
little bit of a follow up to the
original Action Comics story and what I
mean here is that in Action Comics
rebirth of course when the pre new 52
man had fought the pre-new that to
doomsday in the new 52 continuity the
question was how can the pre new 52
Superman defeat doomsday because
whenever doomsday dies he comes back
impervious to what killed him not only
that because the two had fought you know
and and because Superman had died during
the death of Superman story arc in 1992
or whatever was it was released when
doomsday returned every time he came
back he it was more and more difficult
for him to defeat but more more so than
that he had learned battle tactics he
had learned strategy he had learned
deception he learned how to how to trick
Superman and various other forces into
being distracted by other objects by
other people dooms they came to realize
that it'll be more difficult for
Superman to beat him if he were to put
civilians in harm's way intentionally as
opposed to accidentally and so in order
for the preview 52c granted if he
doomsday at the end of that actually
comic story he basically confined
doomsday to the Phantom Zone or at least
believed he had because a Phantom Zone
was inescapable it was a one place that
Superman could put doomsday without ever
having to worry about doomsday coming
back the issue here was that Tuesday was
actually taken before he reached the
Phantom Zone he was kidnapped and he was
used by the what appeared to be time
brokers are appear to be individuals who
are going to use doomsday for their own
purposes now again a lot of this ties
into the ongoing mythos with regards to
mr. Oz who might be Ozymandias from The
Watchmen universe but at this point DC
is only peppered in a little bit of that
stuff and so right now we just kind of
have a series of fragmented appearances
we have no real clue what's going on
with regards to the bigger picture but
for the purpose of this video you know
for the purpose of Superman meeting
Clark Kent this two issue story arc was
simply designed to tell us that this
Clark Kent is literally just a guy that
he was a person that just looked like
the new 52 Superman the new 52 Superman
sent him into hiding in order to keep
him safe and when the new 52 Superman
died that Clark Kent came out of hiding
which resulted in the current
circumstance that were in right now and
so again because of the fact of the
world is now aware that both Clark Kent
and Superman are two completely
different people it basically provides
us with a situation where Dan Jorgensen
kind of go where he wants to with this
Clark Kent we don't know what he'll do
we don't really know what direction the
story will will take all we really know
is that at the mall
and when this thing comes to an end when
the story's brought to an end were left
on a bit of a cliffhanger in the sense
that we're faced with what appears to be
apocalypse the planet of dark side that
has the Superman sigil and some
individual this mysterious person saying
the path is clear the only answer is
death so again we don't really know
where we're going from here but the fact
remains that for those of you guys who
were curious about what was going on
with the Clark and Superman dichotomy
and DC rebirth this video should answer
that question for you guys so again if
you enjoy this make sure you guys hit
the like button make sure you guys hit
the sub button become part of the rock
core and leave a comment tell me what
you guys think and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]
you